bonjour jean louis bricout merci
beaucoup d'être toujours avec nous ce
matin en direct sur rt france un conseil
de défense est prévue demain la décision
d'un reconfirme ans se fait attendre
y êtes-vous favorable et sous quelle
forme écoutez favorable je pense qu'il
ya personne qui est quelque part
favorable au confinement ce sera une
mesure qui sera évidemment difficile à
vivre pour les pour les populations pour
la jeunesse peut-être encore plus
particulièrement est pour pour
l'économie des conséquences qu'il peut y
avoir sur l'économie par rapport à ça je
veux dire aujourd'hui on sent bien et je
crois que les gens s'y attendent quoi va
tendre attendait décision qui sera prise
quel niveau décision sera prise aussi
combien de temps ça peut durer et à quel
moment ça va commencer quoi en relation
peut-être avec les vacances scolaires et
puis le niveau de propagation du virus
et surtout ce qu'on souhaiterait c'est
d'en savoir un peu plus sur l'impact du
variant sur les contaminations parce que
ce sera il ya un équilibre à trouver
entre ces différentes
ces différents constats quoi l'exécutif
qui attend l'impact aussi nu du couvre
feu pour se prononcer le medef lui
l'organisation nationale des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie ont plaidé déjà
pour le maintien de l'ouverture des
commerces
voyez cet appel de geoffroy roux de
bézieux et on en parle après ce qu'on
demande c'est de trouver le bon
équilibre ce bon équilibre serait de
laisser tous les commerces ouverts ne
pas retomber sur le débat essentiel non
essentiels alors voilà il ya cet appel
il ya jean michel blanquer rossi qui dit
qu'il faut maintenir les écoles ouvertes
alors si on laisse tout ouvert à quoi va
ressembler un confinement finalement là
oui effectivement il ya des décisions
qui sont certainement difficile à
prendre sur les commerces
effectivement cette différenciation qui
avait été fait à un moment entre les
commerces essentielles non essentiels on
voit bien qu'en fin de compte si on
ferme les commerces non essentiels on a
des regroupements en 52 population vers
la grande distribution avec en plus si
un appareil du couvre-feu 50 tout le
monde se retrouve coupé même moment
alors les commerces sont essentiels
respecte un mois je le vends quelqu'un
dans la ruralité respecte enfin de
plantes les consignes de distanciation
etc qui permettent quand même de
maîtriser au mieux
c'est une nécessité absolue de fermer
moi je ne pense pas je pense pas que ça
nous amène beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup
mieux quoi en terme de résultats peu
après sur les sur les écoles
effectivement il ya un vrai débat
personne ne souhaite que les écoles
soient soient fermés parce qu'
évidemment il ya de l'impact pédagogique
sur les enfants n'aient vu que
l'enseignement à distance avait quand
même posé quelques problèmes lors du
premier confinement maintenant c'est
vrai que les enseignants mériterait
certainement d'être mieux considéré
mieux protégés quand je vois par exemple
voir budget on a on a transfert
il y a eu quatre plus de 200 millions
qui n'ont pas été consommés qui vont
être reparti en 2021 cd des crédits
qu'ils étaient voués à une meilleure
amélioration des enseignants sein des
équipes pédagogiques
je trouve ça un peu dommage quoi je
trouve qu'il ya peut-être un manque de
respect des équipes enseignantes
oui c'est pour ça qu'ils manifestent
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui partout en france
un mouvement très suivi ordonnées parce
que dans quand même vécu des périodes un
peu particulière au moment des
différentes applications des différents
protocoles et puis on voit bien qu'il ya
une idée des rémunérations qui sont
largement en retrait par rapport à
d'autres lors de ses voeux hier aux
français marine le pen s'est montré
plutôt critique vis-à-vis de la
stratégie du gouvernement
on l'a entendu dans le reportage qui a
précédé ella ella président du
rassemblement national qui est placé en
tête des sondages pour la présidentielle
près de 27% c'est trois points de plus
qu emmanuel macron est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va assister au même duel
qu'en 2017 comme elle le dit d'ailleurs
non contre l'ecosse j'espère pas moche
ce que j'espère c'est que les forces de
gauche puissent se rassembler pour ici
on était rassemblée je pense qu'on
n'aurait pas les scores tel conte
on peut les avoir aujourd'hui qu' on
voit bien que dans les politiques d'une
façon globale
j'espère qu'on aura une réponse de
gauche d'une réponse plus sociale plus
écologique et que on se retrouve pas
effectivement dans le même scénario
qu'on a pu vivre récemment fait perdre
un peu d'espoir mais j'espère que l'on
saura s'allier pour avoir des
candidatures uniques et efficace c'était
ma question on le voit on a vu cette
infographie premier sondage concernant
la présidentielle ce n'est qu'un premier
sondage
évidemment la gauche selon ce sondage
harris interactive est crédité de 7% des
voix les caennais d'algos 5% pour un
arnaud montebourg
loin derrière les 8% et 10% pour les
écologistes pour l'écologiste et yannick
jadot
alors vous pensez vous y croyez vous à
cet assaut front commun à cette union de
la gauche mais j'ai envie d'y croire ont
tués comme bien sûr j'ai comme beaucoup
des suspicions sur les ego des uns des
autres mais je pense qu'on devrait en
tous les cas ce retrouver sur un certain
nombre d'idées sur un projet de société
qui est un projet puisse jouer à gauche
vous avez fort est peut-être pu se
rassembler sur des idées que sur des
hommes parce qu'il n'ya qu'un d'être
toujours ces ego de personnalités partis
qui viennent brouiller un petit peu les
cartes et c'est bien dommage parce que
au regard des populations qui
aujourd'hui sont quand même on voit
notre jeunesse comme aller en souffrance
convient les politiques qui ont été
menées ont apporté plus de pauvreté -
considération aussi pour le pour les
gens qui travaillent
j'espère qu'on pourra se rassembler pour
éviter ce scénario
bien sûr comme vous le dites on est un
ordre un an des élections j'espère que
les choses vont encore évoluer changer
quoi alors justement vous parliez de se
rassembler autour des idées plutôt
qu'autour d'un homme arnaud montebourg
lui ne s'est pas encore déclaré candidat
il a entamé hier un tour de france par
la bretagne est visiblement lui défend
une stratégie hors parti voyez ce qu'on
a pu lire dans ouest france si on en
parle brièvement juste après
arnaud montebourg dont qui était en
déplacement en bretagne regarder ce
qu'on dit ouest france à lannion arnaud
montebourg sera accompagné de deux
députés aient l'air et du sénateur
communiste gérard lahellec un attelage
étonnant mais qui s'explique par la
volonté de l'ancien ministre de brasser
large afin de donner naissance à une
union autour du redressement du pays et
du made in france à l'union autour du
redressement du pays et du made in
france est ce que ce n'est pas là la
bonne idée pour la gauche a je pense que
personne n'est opposé en fin de compte
mail in france effectivement c'est
certainement une idée qui a tendance à
rassembler on a vu même des gens de
droite qui avait l'air de s'intéresser à
ces questions lui évidemment peut-être
un élément essentiel en on a besoin de
favoriser effectivement la production en
france
j'ai même envie de dire que si on
pouvait produire en france tous concours
100 en france évitera et l'impact
écologique ça aussi ça aussi à la rate
et réinsérer vie de déplacement de
transport des marchandises avec tous les
effets sur l'écologie que ça peut avoir
oui je lis rassembler autour d'idées qui
soit le plus large possible qui
rassemble effectivement il ya des enjeux
pour retrouver un peu de gens qui ont
des politiques assez assez modérée à
gauche
en même temps aller chercher ceux qui
ont des idées plus radicale à gauche
jusqu'où il faut aller jusqu'où on peut
rassembler c'est la question du
mouvement évidemment on verra cela on a
le temps pour en parler merci beaucoup
en tout cas jean louis bricout d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur air france merci